(sighs)
- Okay, here we go.
Eric Portis, and today I'll be
speaking on, low self-esteem.
And, for me, it was a
driving force in my life
and it drove me, just like my addiction
did when I was hooked on the crack.
And, it was like my little experience
when my 30 attempts at
getting my life together.
And it drove me like,
the times where I just
couldn't keep my black ass
up out of prison it was those 19 times.
And low self-esteem, it goes hand in hand
with self-deception and self hatred.
And for me, low self-esteem,
that stems from,
growing up, being in an area, being a kid.
And it happened all these
examples around you,
mind you, coming from a
single parent background,
I had some good information.
I have some morals, I
have some values instilled
in me and all that kind of stuff.
And, outside of the family situation,
I got some misinformation,
some stuff that didn't serve a purpose.
And, the low self-esteem
was right in the middle
of it all.
I knew my morals and values
from what my mom taught me 'cause I come
from a single parent background.
And then I knew the streets,
I knew the hustle and the
bustle and all that bullshit
because of my cousin and my brother,
from the street life and
all that kind of stuff.
Then plus all the things that were going
on at that time in my life.
And, so on the outside,
I'm like hip, hip hooray,
everything's good, I'm
getting on, I'm a kid.
Fuck, let's go to Disneyland.
I wanna go to Disneyland
and kick my feet and stuff like that.
But in the inside, it was
something else entirely.
I remember being a kid
and being up all night tossing and turning
because some shit was going on in my mind,
that I just couldn't handle.
And this started around
maybe nine or 10 years old,
feeling like I just didn't belong.
I just wasn't worth it,
I'm like, what the fuck!
How'd I end up here in this
feeling, in this emotion
as a youngster, got all these
things going on inside of me.
And for the life of me,
I couldn't tell nobody
what was really going
on, what I was feeling
'cause I didn't understand
at the time what it was.
I had no inkling, no ideal.
That I suffer from low self esteem.
Self worth, low self worth,
just because of the environment
that I was in, just because
of my household arrangements,
just because of my living situation,
my relationships with people.
That's what brought that shit on.
And boy did a come with
a force and it drove me,
and it drove me for over 20 years.
So I'm wondering why,
why in the fuck am, I'm just going back
and forth to prison, trip after trip.
I say because with some self
worth, some self respect,
then ain't no way in the
world I'ma do anything
to put myself in harm's way,
no shape, form or fashion.
Ain't no way in hell I'ma
put myself in danger,
let alone go to prison 19
times back to back to back
to fucking back.
Now what'd you call that?
I didn't know what it was back then,
but I see now it was low self worth.
'Cause I didn't give a about myself
but I couldn't tell you that,
I couldn't even tell myself that,
'cause I didn't know it at the time.
I'm thinking I'm just
going through emotion
so everybody in the
neighborhood goes to prison
or everybody in the neighborhood's
getting hooked on crack.
That's a motherfucking
lie, everybody don't,
and you don't have to.
I was just one of those unfortunate ones
that had to go through that.
But you can best believe
that, that low self-esteem
and that low self-worth that
shit was a motivating factor
for me getting involved in everything,
that I wasn't supposed to do.
Everything that I wasn't
supposed to experience,
that's exactly what I did.
Because I didn't know, I just didn't care.
I didn't care about me.
I didn't give fuck what you
thought and what you felt.
None of that stuff.
And a cold thing about
it is I remember being
a rebellious teenager.
So I'll go back to maybe,
(sighs) maybe 12 years old.
And, as an example, I wanted
to go to this house party
around the corner because all my friends
is going be there.
And my mom said that I couldn't,
I couldn't attend that
little party that night.
So what I did, I waited
till she went to sleep.
I climbed my black ass up
out the window and I snuck
and I went around the corner
and had the time of my life.
When I came back home, I
couldn't miss getting my whip.
And right after that,
the next day I ran away.
I'ma show your ass.
You hurt me, I'ma hurt
you back in my own way.
It wasn't to hurt her.
I just didn't give a damn,
it didn't matter to me.
I didn't give a fuck what happened to me,
where I ended up at.
Same would experiment
with drugs and alcohol.
I didn't care what the fuck it was.
My thing, my code of honor back then was,
I'll try anything just once.
And I did, for the most part,
there's only a few things
I didn't get to try, these substances,
LSD, no, ecstacy, no.
But for the most part, I have my field.
And, it was all just to
cover up that feeling,
just to cover up that feeling,
those emotions that just
couldn't identify with,
I just couldn't put a finger on.
It's this, or it's that?
So from nine years old up
until through my teens,
that shit was a driving
force where I just did
every and anything, not
to be me, just to escape,
escape that feeling.
'Cause for the life of
me, I couldn't talk about
it to nobody.
And then here go some more shit added
on too because, the direct
result of the drugs,
here come the fucking self deception,
here comes to self hatred,
and some more shit that I
have to add to the equation.
And now I feel like I'm
fucking, I'm in a volcano,
and it's erupting and that is boiling over
but I'm stuck at the bottom
of it just boiling, disintegrating.
Magma just burning my flesh
live from the inside out.
That's what it felt like, dying slowly,
without no fucking rescue
in sight, couldn't see it.
Feelings and emotions and
they're subject to change.
But these motherfuckers
stayed with me for years.
The self-worth, that's stayed
with me for a long time.
Right there, it's like my fucking shadow.
Wake up in the morning,
there it is talking to me.
Like, where this feeling come from?
Why? It always beautiful day outside
but I've got this dark
cloud hovering over me.
I'm like fuck, when it rains, it pours.
I'm like, where does this come from?
It's not raining, it's a beautiful day,
but it's that feeling
consumes me, and it drives me.
So when I'm supposed to do
right, that's what I do.
I do the opposite, I do wrong.
My mom say here's 10 bucks,
go get some milk and bread from the store,
keep the change.
Okay mom, I can do that, be right back.
She won't see me for about two weeks
'cause that 10 fucking dollars and knowing
that I'm supposed to go get
something for the household,
go to the fucking neighborhood crack house
and commence to smoke, knowing
the consequences of that.
Knowing I won't be trusted,
knowing I won't be let back in the house.
Knowing to add onto some
shit from my brother
and my sister and all that kind of stuff.
He didn't did it again?
You got to be kidding me.
Mom, not again. That's
the kind of shit I was on.
And it happened on a regular
basis in different shapes,
in different fashions.
I wasn't playing
I seriously knew nothing
about committing suicide.
I was just thinking, I
was hoping at the time
that it occurred faster than
the way it was happening
'cause my suicide was like,
okay, I'm gonna get a $20 crack rock.
I'm gonna put the whole thing on a pipe
and take one big ass hit
and try to burst my motherfucking chest.
That was the way I saw it, but
it didn't turn out that way.
I took the big ass hit, fucking...
And got a fucking brain shocking
and pass out on the ground.
I remember one time, scared me to death
but not enough to stop me.
I was in the alley and
I was squatting down
and I squatted, took me a
big ass motherfucking hit.
And then, you know what?
Now mind you, it's about 12 noon
and I'm on the side of this
dumpster, this trashcan.
And, I woke up sprawled out
in the middle of the alley.
And when I came to, I'm fucking
looking up and it's dark
and I'm like, where am I?
'Cause I'm looking
at these big old cypress
trees and everything.
And I must have laid in
that alley unconscious maybe
for a few hours.
(siren wailing)
It was all, it wasn't dark but it was late
in the evening 'cause I
remember the difference
in the temperature from
when I took that hit
it was nice and sunny.
And when I woke my ass up,
it was breezy, it was windy.
(siren wailing)
And, scared me to death,
'cause I was thinking,
somebody could have
walked through this alley
and saw me, and just hurt me real bad.
And that was a reality shock for a minute
but then it wore off.
And here I have to go again
with some more motherfucking
daily experiences,
playing with some shit, playing with fire,
throwing rocks at the penitentiary.
'Cause I just didn't
know how to deal with,
deal with what was the truth at the time,
truth was I feel like a piece of shit.
I just didn't belong, I feel
like I just didn't fit in.
I don't give a fuck if I
was born to a rich family.
I probably would have had those
same feeling and emotions.
They didn't mean 'cause I was black,
poor and in real trouble,
they ain't got to do with it.
'Cause it was a lot of good times,
I had a lot of good experiences,
a lot of good memories.
It wasn't all bad. It
was just that feeling.
I just couldn't, I just didn't
know how to deal with it.
So that's the driving
force, that led me left
when I should have went right, every time.
(sighs)
It was a part of my character makeup
by the time I hit my twenties
and I knew what it was,
by then I knew exactly
what that feeling was.
'Cause I've been dealing
with it for so long
because during those late
teens going into my twenties,
I said, well let me try to get my shit,
let me try to get myself together,
and stopped doing because
the way I was headed,
in my experiences were going to prison.
Because by the time I was 18,
I already, I had three
stints in the county jail
before I was 18.
So by the time I hit 18, I
was in the state penitentiary.
And, came home and went right back at 20.
And I stayed gone till like
22, almost 23 years old
'cause I did 16 would have like 10 months,
stayed home maybe six
months and went right back
for four years.
So they gave me about 27 months
so they go two years,
right before you know it.
Now mind you, I went to fire camp.
So my experience in prison,
it was like fucking adventure,
I just couldn't believe it.
So I went in scrawny and
skinny and came out looking
like Lou Ferrigno, "The Incredible Hulk."
And that's what I felt like.
But here on the back end,
that feeling was with me too,
but it just wasn't strong
enough to make me wanna mess
up immediately after I came home
'cause I wanted to try
something different.
So that's when I began to recognize
it for what it was, low self-esteem.
And some more shit that
I added to the equation
by my experiences with doing
wrong, with doing bad things
and the people, picking
up those bad habits
and all that kind of stuff.
'Cause you pick 'em up
along the way. I know I do.
And I carried 'em, I carried
'em like my backpack for years,
on my shoulders.
And they was heavy than a motherfucker.
I'm talking about heavy,
burdensome, tiresome,
toiling through the day.
I felt like the Israelites in
the wilderness for 40 years.
Because I just couldn't
see no relief inside
of my neighborhood 'cause it
was always something going
on in the neighborhood and it wasn't good.
It wasn't all bad, but God damn!
Something, shit be like,
can that shit just go ahead and blow over
and just pass by now.
But it seemed like year after year,
after year after year things
got a little bit worse
in the neighborhood.
Crack became more epidemic,
crack houses appeared more.
Despair came, depression, some
shit I wasn't even ready for.
I had no ideal, but it was all
going on and it was happening
in my neighborhood right before my eyes.
And I'm like, oh my God! what is this?
Shit, ain't no way in hell
I'm gonna get off some damn crack.
'Cause you had a crack
house in every other house,
just like they have the
liquor stores on every corner
and a church, side-by-side
competing with each other
for your fucking soul,
now ain't that some shit.
You got all these churches
in the neighborhood,
it's like a thousand of
them in a six block radius,
competing, but I didn't see 'em out there,
come into the crack house,
come into the alleyways
and the byways, talking
and trying to get you,
you had to go there.
And I'm like if I have to
go to your ass, I'm good.
Motherfucker, I need you
out here, where I'm at,
meet me somewhere in the middle, shit.
Come by passing out some flowers
or something and we'll talk.
You say, well meet me
at church or something,
I think you, think I can help you,
then I would've did it gladly.
So, I had a resentment yes, to
churches in the neighborhood
'cause every time I'm going
to and fro from hustling
from stealing and robing or come and going
from the crack house, I'm
looking at the churches,
I'm looking at the cross and
all that, the Protestants
and Catholics and the
Espanolas, whatever that is.
And I'm like, all these
different organizations,
all of these different names.
Baptist and all that kind of stuff.
And I said, when I finally come around
I wanted to do something
non-denominational
'cause I don't wanna claim nothing
when it comes to religion,
because I grew up with,
it was all in the neighborhood,
but I didn't see 'em.
They was always behind closed
doors except on Sundays.
And then when I walked my
tired, nasty toe up ass
by the church, they
wouldn't let me up in there,
the way I was looking or
the way I was smelling.
They'd shun me what
you wanna come in here?
Hell yeah, I wanna come in now there,
I'm tired motherfucker, wanna
rest my feet for a minute.
Is that okay with you, sir?
Talking to the deacon.
I'm sorry, but yeah, you
can't, church service
is almost over why'd you
try back next Sunday.
I know that was motherfucker lying to me,
and I didn't blame him.
'Cause if I would see
him, if I was in his shoes
I probably would have
said the same exact thing.
You ain't getting your ass up in here.
Lord knows you might
go up in here and take
every thing motherfucking
that's not well down.
And he was probably right,
if I had the opportunity.
I know I wasn't gonna put
no money in the plate,
so if the plate pass by me,
best believe I was gonna
take something out that plate
and put it in my pocket.
Desperate, didn't give a
fuck, give a fuck about me,
cared about my future, my
outlook, my shit was bleak.
And so, I just walked by the churches
and on Sundays sat outside
and imagined would it be
like being on the other side,
crossing that threshold,
and going one Sunday half-ass clean,
with a shower, maybe some
jeans and a fucking T-shirt
or a tank top or something,
minus the ball cap.
And, I didn't get to see
that happen in my twenties,
but something else happened
and that was just me trying
to get myself together,
going through the rehabs.
And so the more I started
doing the self realizations
and all that kinda stuff.
And, the more information
I got from different people
and all that kind of stuff, I said,
okay I can pinpoint that
feeling and emotion,
that low self-esteem.
I said, that shit's been a
guiding force for me forever.
I said, something got to
change, something gotta happen.
Because it's ruling me,
and it's taken me down
these highways and byways,
where there's just, there's
only doom and gloom.
And there's only three
alternatives for me,
from my experiences
coming to the realization
that effect was I ended up in prison,
I end up in rehabs or end up
homeless, had a guiding force.
Those were my only three
alternatives that I've had,
dealing with that bullshit.
So I felt like I was
really in dire streets.
When I'll say in my mid thirties,
when I said, God damn, I'm
dealing with self deception,
most definitely self hatred,
most definitely low self
esteem, low self-worth.
I said, no, I thought that
the 'L' word meant for love.
I don't know where this
low shit came from,
added to the words, to the equation.
But there was no love and it
wasn't no love and a picture,
I couldn't even see it for me.
Love me, what? Like me,
you've got to be kidding me,
you out your fucking mind,
get outta here with that shit.
That's the furthest thing from the truth.
I might tell you that, might
tell you everything's fine
and all that kind of stuff
and put up a good fight
but deep inside, I didn't have
it, I didn't have that fight.
I didn't have that desire,
it just overwhelmed me.
And I gave in.
Every time I got a hand get
to me, to get my together,
to get my life together
and I fold the chords,
it had one up on me, one up,
'cause I knew what it was.
It wasn't me, it was that feeling.
It was Zad, I knew what it was.
Every time I had an opportunity to get
to a program or to get my shit together
and I squandered that opportunity,
I knew exactly what it was.
It didn't take no rocket scientist.
I've been in situations, in
positions, where I had action,
where God sent those
guardian angels down right
then in the nick of time to help me,
and, I will piss on it,
just on a opportunity
and let it go by.
And you can best believe me
somebody more well-deserving
than me got that opportunity
and got that chance
to a new life and I'm
pretty sure they got it.
And I'm pretty sure to living today beyond
their wildest dreams, 'cause
that's how I am today,
I feel it, it just took
me a long time to get it.
But everybody gets a
turn. I had many chances.
I had many turns.
So, it's not easy, but it's not easy.
But the thing that kind of stopped me,
and it kept me like in a
straight, was not denial.
It wasn't the fact that I
didn't know what was going
on because I did.
I just feel like I had
no choice in the matter
I had no say so in this
matter, what can I do?
Shit, I'm only one man,
because it started as a child
so back then my excuse was, what can I do?
I'm only a kid.
I can't even identify what's going on.
Then when I got to the teenage years
it was like, come on, I'm just a teenager
what you expect, robing
and stealing and shooting
the shit and experiment with all that.
Come on, it come with the territory.
And it did come with the
territory to some degree, it did.
Where I was raised at of
course, shit in the ghetto.
You gonna try every motherfucking thing.
And, I did, everything
that it had to offer.
I'm gonna be first in
line, for that, for this.
But when I got to my
twenties, then I couldn't use
that excuse no more,
come on, I'm just a kid,
that come with the territory
and all that bullshit
'cause it didn't, because I
saw where my life is going.
And I saw the turmoil I was in.
I saw myself in that big
ass pot, lost in the sauce.
I'm like, I got to get up outta here.
I can't last too much longer.
I'm being a stirred in this mixture, shit.
'Cause I'm going deeper
and deeper into the pot,
submerging, it's gonna
be hard for me to come
from under that, because of the stuff
that I was adding to it, the different...
(sighs)
Habits that I picked up,
character traits from others.
And, so in my mid thirties,
I decided to do something about it.
And that's where the help came from.
And, when people came and
offered help, I took it.
You damn right I did.
Shit, I'm crazy but I'm not that crazy.
'Cause I was tired, sick and
tired of being sick and tired
of the bullshit, of the self
hatred and all that bullshit
the low self-esteem, please.
I know I'm better than
that. I've got to be.
I know there's more to me than that.
Even though that was the
driving force in my life.
I knew there was more
to me than just that.
I'd say well shit now,
I'm looking at all my liabilities
I'm like what fuck are the assets?
Where are my assets at?
What are pros and cons
when it comes to me,
let me take a look.
'Cause it's been a long
time, because I was so stuck
in that bullshit, I
couldn't see anything good
'cause I couldn't see the
forest from the trees.
And I can be deep in the valley
or I can be on a mountain top.
I'll just be focusing on the
trees instead of the horizon
that was out there, overlooking the trees,
how beautiful is the sunset
and all that kinda stuff
or the color of the sky.
Or many clouds and the
shape of the clouds.
So I'm stuck on the fucking trees,
'cause I can't look up, 'cause
I'm so busy looking down,
'cause that was my life down, shit.
I didn't have no reason
to hold my head up high,
straight back and all that bullshit
with a smile on my face,
welcoming, that wasn't me.
It wasn't bleak, but
God damn that wasn't me.
I didn't always look
down, but I see eight out
of 10 times when I used to
leave the house and I go,
I'm looking down, consumed by some shit
that I don't even know
that's just driving me,
and guiding me, to these places unknown.
And that's the cold situation of being,
that's the cold life
that you have to endure.
I had to endure that shit
and I had to go through it.
And I wouldn't wish that
on nobody, on nobody,
not my worst enemy.
Thank God, I came to a
place where I just said,
I can't take no more, I
give up, fuck that shit.
I've got to do something because it starts
with me and it ends with me
just like the way it started
when I was a kid and couldn't identify.
As I got into adulthood and
then I saw through what it was,
I said, well there's
something I can do about it.
And that's where the effort came
and I had to put forth
some kind of effort.
So, when people came and said,
hey, would you like to do this?
Yes sir, yes mom,
and that's where those 30
trips to rehab came from.
I tried that shit 30 times.
I want more than what
this shit has to offer me.
I want more than this has to
offer me, and I wasn't playing.
Took me 30 times to get it,
but shit at least I knew
what I was dealing with.
I wasn't in denial about nothing.
I knew exactly what it
was, and it was killing me.
And it had been killing me for the longest
I don't know how many years,
but at least knew what it was finally.
Okay. So that was my starting place.
I thank God for creating me the way
He has because I'm not a
quitter, I'm a fighter.
Now, I might've thought the
wrong fight over the years
and fighting for the wrong cause.
Because, I was a hell of a fucking hustler
out there on streets,
when I was out there in that lifestyle.
I was somebody to be reckoned with,
well I wasn't playing out there.
When I was hustling and bustling
and all that kind of stuff.
When I was smoking that crack
and hustling to get that shit.
I was a force to be reckoned with.
So I said, well, let's
try to flip the script
on this and see if I can
be a force to be reckoned
with something good, something positive.
And, those are my goals today.
What can I contribute? What can
I add to the equation today?
Good, something positive.
So that keeps me from going
backwards into that doom
and gloom and that fucking
bullshit, low self-esteem
and self-worth, I don't buy that no more.
You can sell it to me.
Take that shit somewhere
else to somebody else
who don't know no better, I do.
So, when it comes to
dealing with individuals,
men and women, and I see it
in 'em, I've talked to 'em
and I share some stuff,
but if they ain't trying
to get up out of it, I'm gone.
'Cause I don't want that
shit jumping back on me
'cause I know how long I
had to carry mine around
before I was finally free.
So if somebody else has it
and I see it for what it is,
because it's me, I see you and me.
And I share some stuff about
it and you take no heed,
I said, shit, that was me in my thirties.
I was just the same,
I was the same way when
so-and-so tried to talk to me.
I did the same reaction,
I said the same fucking exact thing.
You got to be kidding me, deja vu.
And, still thank God that I
could see it for what it is,
and that I can help too.
In times of need, if I
can, I put it out there
and I let them know shit you're not alone.
And you probably don't have
to go through it as long
as I did.
For some reason people like
me go through some shit.
And it is just, I can't
even put a name on it.
It's not my place to speak on
somebody else's experience.
But I know there's a lot of people
like me whose trials and tribulations
are exactly the same, are similar.
And I'm talking about
for the men and women.
It's just, I just have to
see it for what it was.
I can't blame it on the neighborhood.
I can't blame it on the upbringing.
I can't blame it on being poor.
I can't blame it on being black.
God damn! I got to see it for what it is.
Those are valid excuses and
it might've added to it,
but that's not the foundation
that it's based on.
It's based on me having
fears, human nature
and I just slept my human natures impose
their will on me, when it came to that,
the negative instincts, instead
of the natural instincts.
My natural instinct is to
get up to go to school,
to do good and all that kind of bullshit.
But the bad nature part of
the flip side of it was,
like I said before, a
driving force in my life.
And I'm just glad that I'm finally off
that roller-coaster ride.
I'm gonna share something, before I close.
I remember being in the
crack house one time,
think I had a thousand dollars
I had just tucked stopped
in this doing a scene.
And, I went to their fucking
credit cards got some stuff,
I said, now I better go to the motel
for this experiment that I'ma do.
So I got a room for two hours and I said,
I'm going to smoke for the
whole two hours until it's time
to leave and whatever I have
left I'm just going to hide it,
flush it, or whatever.
I knew damn well, I wouldn't flush it,
I think I ended up taking it with me
after the two hours was up,
whatever I didn't finish.
I remember I said, every
time I blow the smoke out,
I'ma to feel like I'm
on a roller-coaster ride
and I'ma close my eyes.
And when I blow the
smoke and I'ma act like
I'm on this ride.
And, I think I must have
closed my eyes a thousand times
in that two hours, that
I was in that room.
And, before the end of the experiment
when I took a hit off the crack pipe
and close my eyes and blew the smoke out,
I got the weave and I got
the ducking and all that,
like I was hitting all the
turns 'cause on the right
when it was gonna dip, on the
right when it was gonna go up,
on the right one was gonna go left,
I'm the one that's gonna
turn right to sharp turn.
And I had that whole experience
that ride, fuck that ride.
That's the ride I don't wanna take.
'Cause I was on that ride
for many, many years.
I was wonderful,
why can't I get off this
damn roller-coaster ride?
But every time, no matter where I was at,
I took a hit off the crack
pipe and blow off the smoke.
I might not get it the experiment
but that's exactly what it felt like.
Like I was on a roller-coaster ride
and I know all it dips and turns,
I don't care where I was at.
And I came full circle
with low self-esteem
Because it was one day
I'm up, one day I'm down,
one day I'm up, high, low,
in, out, all these turns
and all that kind of
stuff and twist to it.
I just have to slow down
long enough to get my take
in on it and see it for what it was.
And my best teacher
was my life experience,
all the places I've
traveled, all the roads
I've been on and all the places I've been,
and all the things I've
done that kind of showed me,
that he gave me that roadmap.
And I said, okay I see
clearly now what's going on.
And that's my saving
grace, having the courage
to see it for what it is and
do the best I can and work
with it and try to overcome
it, get to the other side.
'Cause I know wherever
there's a lesson that I learn,
then there's a blessing
coming right behind it.
Every time I drop a bad
character trait or a bad habit
and try something different,
there's always something
good that follows,
always an open door.
I never dropped a bad habit or a bad vice
and then encountered a closed door.
I mean a open door is just opportunity
that's all it means to
me, always an open door.
So behind every lesson that I learned
there was a blessing,
believe that cause I do, wholeheartedly.
It's not easy but it's
not hard today for me,
getting through some shit,
learning some more stuff,
staying open to anything good.
Keeping my eyes and my
mind open to any new
and all information.
'Cause it helps me, it doesn't hurt me.
I'll try anything that helps,
anything that's a healing
process, I'm with that.
And since I stay by myself
and I do my own thing,
so at home and I clean, I love
cleaning and I love listening
to my music, and I love my punk rock.
Get to the bathroom, I was,
right before coming here,
I did my bathroom, I was
in there for maybe an hour.
45 minutes in the shower, love my music.
The music just, that's
my driving force today,
that's what drives me.
Thank God I got to that side,
thank God I get to see
that for what it is.
'Cause that's a beautiful thing for me.
You mean that's what, yeah
that's what drives me.
And I don't have to be hurt behind it,
I don't have to hurt nobody
behind, I don't have to end
up in prison and all that other
manners that come with it.
This feeling, this emotion,
you've got to be shitting me.
No, I'm not, that's God's honest truth.
'Cause there was a time in my life
where I couldn't live
with them without me.
But now I wouldn't want it any other way.
And that's the truth Dr. Ruth, thank you.